the three great essentials to achieve
anything worthwhile our hardwork
stick-to-itiveness and common sense the
three great essentials to achieve
anything worthwhile our hardwork
stick-to-itiveness and common sense
perseverance hard work and common sense
gosh it didn't say a PhD from a high-end
institution hmm I wouldn't on the list
that's interesting if you were to sit
down and tell your 14 year old or your
14 year old niece or nephew or your 14
year old neighbor kid what the secret to
success is what would you tell them get
a degree at any cost
studying anything from anywhere and
you'll be okay is that what you would
tell them that's what some people seem
to have heard worse than that you and I
are financing that garbage instead we
should maybe teach youngsters and
oldsters it's hard work it's
perseverance it's common sense
see I'm a little tired of everybody
talking about forgiving student loans
and making student loans bankrupt able
without first doing away with the
problem I admit that the student loan
problem is a huge issue and it's a major
problem for some of you I get that and
I'm not unsympathetic to that but if
it's such a bad thing that we've done to
all these young people why are we not
presenting legislation to stop it
because the only reason there's so many
student loans is our
ensure the first thing we should do stop
federally insuring student loans
immediately right now then we can talk
about what to do with the people that
are in a mess but you can't keep putting
people in a mess and try to fix the mess
the first step is to stop putting people
into the mess it's not working
it's an abject epic failure it's
destroyed people's lives it's had an
effect on the spiritual economy of this
nation Oh people were trying to be a do
a good thing but they didn't when a
winner is never quit yeah they do they
quit doing stupid stuff all the time the
student loan program federally insured
by the federal government is a stupid
thing and it needs to stop now we the
people need to quit letting Congress in
our name using our signature insure
loans that put young people deeply into
debt so they can't breathe we need to
stop it well you're against education no
I'm against stupidity
I'm not against education at all but I
would combine education with character
of hard work perseverance and common
sense and since mathematically have
proven repeatedly on the show you can go
through college and get a four-year
degree without student loan debt the
idea that the federal government must
ensure it is absolutely ridiculous it's
moronic and so I don't get into politics
a lot just when it's messing up people's
lives but this idea of we're gonna
forgive student loans that maybe some
to talk about but you can't even have
that conversation logically we need to
forgive them why because they've damaged
so many people but we're gonna keep
giving them out that's so dumb that's
the critical thinking skills of that
statement are just moronic so you know I
gotta agree with some of the people on
the left that we need to do something
with a student luminous but the first
thing is stop making the mess before you
can even have a logical conversation
about what to do with the mess you have
to admit it's a mess and so why would we
continue to do it if it's a mess it's a
mistake it's a problem it's idiotic it's
moronic it needs to stop it's harming
people your government is harming its
citizens think about that I mean that's
what we're all sitting around saying
when we talk about these poor children
that are trapped in their student loans
although I know they're not all trapped
and get them I mean I see them here
every week getting out of debt I know
you can do it I know if you've got
student loan debt you're gonna make it
and I'm not suggesting you wait around
the government to fix your problem
that'd be dumber than Iraq but from a
policy standpoint the government should
not be engaged in things that bring harm
to people come on I mean this is proven
it is an epic abject failure I mean do
you have is there anyone that is of a
thinking person that has two brain cells
to rub together they can actually look
at me in the face and say oh the student
loan program federally insured by the
federal government is a wonderful
success well that would make you on the
head of the list of morons it's
obviously not a success do some good
things possibly come out of it that's
not the point some good things come out
of a car wreck but that doesn't mean we
need to have car wrecks
that's a dumb but idea you can find good
out of almost anything you get enough
manure you can grow things with it I
mean come on there's good in almost
anything but that doesn't mean it
doesn't stink to high heaven and that's
where we are so Tommy Edison
tells us the way it is the three great
essentials to achieve anything
worthwhile our hardwork
stick-to-itiveness and common sense it
is not a degree or a graduate level
degree from a prestigious university and
left handed puppetry and then wonder why
there's not a huge job market for left
handed puppetry and how the entire
culture has let you down and how you now
have been ripped off and you've been
told a lie the great lie of Education
and just not true character is more
important at the end of the day
perseverance common sense hard work are
more important at the end of the day
there are a bigger part of the equation
of your success than where you go to
school or what you study now I'm big on
education I want you to go to school I
want you to study I do not want a
culture full of people that are have
never academically trained that is not a
good thing I love smart people I hang
out with them all day here I try not to
hire dumb people if I can figure it out
and so we just you know we're careful
about that but the thing is this folks
as everyone is all up in arms talking
about the Student Loan debacle maybe you
and I need to start a movement or we
just start destroying our congressmen
and our Senators with the amount of
emails that we're sending saying stop
harming our children hashtag there you
go hashtag stop harming our children and
the student loan guarantee debacle let
me help you with what will happen the
number of people going to school and not
watching what they pay for it because
it's borrowed money will stop everyone
will start watching what they pay for it
you know what that will do the cost of
tuition at every school it will drive it
down it's called a supply demand curve
it's econ in the set
grade hmm I'm fixing a whole bunch of
stuff here in about five minutes this is
why I couldn't be a politician because I
make way too much sense